The bedrock of Unreal's networking is replication.
So let's break down what replicates and when.
Simply put, variable replication is the process
of sending an authoritative value
of a variable over the network.
Networked actors have got a net update frequency
and this is used to determine
how often an actor replicates.
The server keeps track of shadow data
and this is essentially a copy of the last value
that was sent to each client.
The server compares the shadow data
against its current set of values
and if there's a disparity,
we'll try and send an updated value down to that client,
bringing it back in sync.
This check comes with an inherent network cost.
So if we don't anticipate this value changing very often,
we can reduce the net update frequency
on a per actor basis.
Managing the net update frequency rates
is fairly low hanging fruit
in regards to improving network performance.
Like most areas of engineering,
if we can do something less, then we probably should.
One element of networking that is often forgotten
is how do we handle clients joining midway through a game?
How Unreal handles replication for these new clients
is to simply send down the authoritative data
as soon as they connect.
After all, their default values
are likely to be out of sync with the server,
thus triggering a disparity through a net update.
Not all types can be replicated.
Some are strongly supported,
some absolutely are not strongly supported
and some require a bit of nuance
on the part of the developer to get them to play nice.
So straight off the bat, we've got our atomic types,
that being the bools, the ints and the floats.
We also have support for structs
that contain these atomic types.
These can be sent over the network
as a single block of data.
Enums can also be replicated.
They take advantage of their underlying Uint8 typing
to be sent over the network
and then are coerced back into their enum types
on the other side.
Arrays are also supported with only their changed elements
being sent over the network at any one time.
It's worth noting, however,
that if you RPC down an array,
the whole array will be sent,
not just the changed elements.
Unfortunately, there's no current support
for serialization of TMaps.
A very common and easy alternative to this data structure
is to have an array of structs instead
and replicate that array.
Pointers are supported for replication,
but only when the thing it's pointing to
is replicated in its own right.
Under the hood, the pointer gets turned into a GUID.
It's this GUID that then gets sent over the network
in place of that pointer.
When the GUID is received on the client,
we can then marry it back up
to the actor that it once pointed to,
rebuilding the pointer on the client.
To make a variable replicated,
we need to do the following.
Firstly, we need to make sure
we're working with a replicated object,
and that can either be calling set replicated to true
when working with an actor,
typically called in the body of the constructor.
Alternatively, we need to call set is replicated
by default if we're working with a component.
Finally, if we're working with a blueprint
that supports replication,
setting the be replicate flag to true in the class defaults
will also cause this object to replicate.
To actually flag a variable as replicated,
we have a couple of options.
Firstly, we can add the replicated property specified
to the variable,
and this is the most basic form of replication.
When this variable changes server side,
it's gonna propagate down to all of the relevant clients.
Alternatively, we can use the replicated
using property specifier,
and this will also propagate the change down,
but it will also let developers specify a function to call
once the value has arrived.
In this example, when the property changes,
the my func function is called,
allowing us to drive gameplay
as soon as we have an update.
It's worth noting that a value will not be replicated
if the value that you set it to on the server
is the same as the value on the client,
because it hasn't actually changed after all.
Similarly, if your game can run in both single
and multiplayer environments,
we must be diligent in making sure critical gameplay
isn't done in on rep functions.
If we're running a single player game,
the on rep isn't going to be called.
Lastly, we need to override
the get lifetime replicated props function of your class,
flagging to the engine that this variable
needs to be replicated.
And we do this by employing the do rep lifetime macro
as outlined above.
Do rep lifetime is just the base macro.
However, we can actually employ
the do rep lifetime condition macro instead.
This will let us specify a specific condition
that needs to be met before this variable
is considered for replication.
Something that is often forgotten
when working with replication
is that the actual act of replicating takes time.
A client may hit a big patch of lag
just after you send the variable over the network.
So it's critical we take this into account
when we write our systems.
We might send two values over the network
and have them arrive in a different order.
So we really need to waterproof our systems
against common and easy gotchas like this.
For instance, we can wrap our two variables in a struct
and send that over the network instead,
ensuring they arrive at the same time.
Another critical thing we need to take into account
is how well our clients deal with a lack of information.
If we're moving something
and replicating its new location,
do we just stop moving it
while we wait for the next packet?
Of course not.
We often want to consider elements of client side
prediction when we work with larger systems
to make client interactions
feel more responsive and smooth.
I'd highly recommend we take a look
at the character movement component
as a real standard example
of how we can smooth out a client experience
so the server is essentially invisible.